tratamiento de antibióticos al que fue
sometido el Papa Francisco en el
hospital para tratar la bronquitis
infecciosa que le fue diagnosticada
produjo los efectos esperados y permitió
su salida del hospital esta mañana
Después de tres días de hospitalización
a pesar de esto la salud de Francisco
permanece delicada tiene 86 años Y
seguramente Durante los próximos días
deberá protegerse al máximo para no
resfriarse mañana domingo El Vaticano ha
confirmado su presencia en la misa del
domingo de Ramos pero personas cercanas
al soberano pontífice me han dicho que
esto podría cambiar en cualquier momento
las próximas horas serán cruciales para
determinar si el pontífice está
efectivamente en condición de participar
a las liturgias papales de la Semana
Santa el calendario Vaticano preveía
siete ceremonias presididas por el Papa
Francisco hasta el domingo 9 de abril